Julio Rodriguez there is so much for us
to discuss but first off thank you for
coming on we are very happy to have you
no thank you for having me here of
course of course absolutely well we have
to begin with this campaign
congratulations tops is such an iconic
brand obviously now a part of the
prominent Fanatics family and you are
the 2023 series one cover star so what
does something like this mean for your
career such a big moment uh I mean it
means a lot because I feel I just I just
remember when I was a kid back in the VR
um I was one of cards I never really
thought that it was going to be possible
for me to like even be on the car and
for me to be on the cover of the top
series one is definitely it means a lot
to me because just thinking back there
like how a watch as a kid like now like
how far I've come uh it's pretty cool
so for somebody who maybe doesn't
understand just how big Collectibles are
in the baseball Community why do cards
mean so much to Baseball fans and to
baseball players
um I just feel like you always see it as
a kid I feel like coming up I remember I
used to always see them and it's kind of
hobby like a part of the player that you
look up to or while your favorite
players so I feel like that's kind of
what it means it's gonna have like that
little part of somebody that you look up
to or that that you basically root for
definitely okay when you were growing up
did you collect any baseball cards uh
unfortunately not I just I just had this
one visual card from Pedro when he was
in the Mets and that was the only car
yeah that was the only car that I used
to I used to have I remember I don't
remember how I got to my house but
that's the only one I own
yeah but it was probably so special
had this one one card and you just
knew right yeah
this person to me and that's why I said
like I used to see Pedro on those cards
and I never thought that it came from
America me that I'll probably be on a
car like just to be like the face of the
product right now it just it's very
special
I love that well you deserve it tops
sent me a bunch of your card packs I
opened some and we're gonna play a
little game okay okay perfect
I'm gonna give you three Clues and
you're gonna guess the player that's on
the card okay oh wow
our second clue you tell me the answer
but if you need all three Clues we can
do that okay are you ready obviously I
hope okay
this is a current player whose dad
played in MLB
he led the National League in home runs
in 2021
and he has been on the cover of MLB the
Show previously
the national heat 2021 he said and his
dad played an MLB
he also has a huge personality
he led the annual home runs in 2021
tatis
[Music]
all right you got that one
all right you ready for your next one
what do you got for me
okay three time National League MVP
member of the 3 000 hit Club
fourth all time in home runs
what's in Behavior play for he was a
machine uh-huh
what team did he play for
I'll give you a clue the team that he's
really known for playing for there is an
arch in this city oh
oh Albert Pujols
ding ding ding ding ding all right
you've got it okay let's do let's do one
more
this player
first round pick by the Marlins in 2010
hit for the cycle three times
One National League MVP in 2018. oh
that's Christian jealous
look at this you're good at this game
okay do you want to do one do you wanna
do one more are you good at three I mean
I'm going with three but I always got
one more okay we always got one more
let's do it let's see how good you are
okay final one hopefully Adam
yeah you're like oh
it's the tricky one
okay I bet this is gonna be the hardest
one for me for talking
we'll see let's see if you can back it
up okay pitched at UCLA oh my God has
pitched for three different teams
currently the third highest paid pitcher
in MLB
the Third
the third highest and when people think
of him a lot of people think of the
place and the city that I'm in right now
Jacob degrom
no
uh
uh treaty Gary Cole
yes let's go all right you went four for
four I'll take it I love it okay so I
have these other two packs I'm not gonna
open them now because I want to keep one
to collect for myself but then I'm just
I'm curious what's in what's in the
other one so I'll let you know who else
we have but there were some good players
in the Box really good players yeah no I
love it okay what five players would you
have in your dream tops pack in my dream
tops back I mean You Gotta Throw guys
guys like Mike Trout in it you know like
my trial like nice my trial
405 rookie card
uh uh let me see
one from one Soto
that's a pretty good one I would say
who else let me see who else
[Music]
I want like one mookie beds
oh good choice yeah one day he's one of
my favorite players too
uh who else who else who else I would
like to this is a good pack so far
uh
how many more I need two more two more
I'm gonna throw one from Pedro just to
kind of for the the memories from that
car it's just to see if we can get
something nice from Pedro and one for
myself why not
I love that yeah we'll go well I would
love some of my rookie cards yeah I
think if somebody got that packed they
would be incredibly pleased to have all
of those uh Heavy Hitters in one tops
pack uh one thing that you talk about a
lot of course is growing up in the
Dominican Republic what that meant to
your life obviously and your career but
what is your earliest baseball memory
my earliest based on memory is playing
baseball with my dad with a stick and
he's throwing me tennis ball that's
literally I can remember in the back of
the in the back of my house in the
backyard that's I love it that's my
earliest memory on baseball and he was
the one that showed me the game he was
the one that basically showed me the
love for the game the passion bought it
so
you know that's my memory
that's so great so what do you think is
the biggest thing that you took from
your dad when it comes to playing on the
field
oh this is playing with heart playing
with hard play with passion and like but
somebody if you have a bad day like they
are going to come because baseball was
just so hard like in baseball you're not
gonna go like 10 for 10 all the time and
things like that so uh there's
definitely struggles but I feel like I
always enjoy I always loved the game I
always have passion for it and do it the
right way I feel like that's the biggest
thing I do for my dad
for sure so I was watching your speech
for Al Rookie of the Year it was great
but in it you mentioned that you have
always had a lot of questions and you
would always ask players and they were
always so gracious giving you their time
giving you their answers and the player
that you mentioned was Aaron judge what
are some of the questions that you have
asked Aaron judge and what have his
answers been
um I feel like
we talk we talked definitely baseball
and approach and I don't want to give
that away but I also talked to him like
how the how does he do it how does he
handle like all the pressure just being
basically the key in New York and like
all this stuff you know like how does
this handle himself and it would just
basically just keep being you keep being
yourself or Never Lose Yourself that's
and that's basically why he told me like
short words basically and I really took
that for me like too hard and I got to
talk to him in that ceremony there and
it was pretty good to see him again
so keeping you keeping yourself those
are certainly wise words from Aaron
judge but how have you handled that
pressure as well it feels like your life
has moved really quickly you're just
this sensation in baseball now how have
you handled that I was just the same
just saying like that I feel like it was
it was good hearing that from him like a
guy that I've already been through it
and he just basically gave me
reassurance that what I've been doing is
right you know and just gotta say on my
Lane been doing my doing my thing trying
to get better like work you basically
keep keep doing what got me here that's
basically what how I'm approaching it
absolutely in that same speech you said
that people should never let somebody
put limits on them that they should know
that they can do whatever it is they set
their mind out to do
can you give me a moment that maybe
somebody doubted you and you proved them
wrong uh I feel like one was coming up
through the miners I feel like there's a
lot of people
like everybody pretty much they always
have that stamp on me that I wasn't
going to be able to run or I wasn't
going to be able to play in center field
or things like that that I was going to
be at most a good right fielder because
I was going to get thick even whenever I
first signed oh he's gonna get chubby
whenever he's like 20 something or 21 or
he just go he just happened bad he
doesn't play defense very well and this
is like that I feel like I'm not gonna
be whoever you want to be I know what I
got inside of me I know all the work
that I've been putting in I know all
that you don't know that you're not next
to me every every day whenever I'm
working and I feel like all those all
those all those things coming up through
the miners that's the label that people
had on me I was like okay like whenever
I have the time you guys are all gonna
see and I did I wasn't I wasn't talking
back on people I wasn't saying Oh no
you're wrongful thinking like that I was
just alerted them I feel like my only
duty was to go out to the field and show
show them why what I'm really capable of
and who I really am so that was kind of
that I took that was kind of something
that I took from my experience and I
just encourage people to just go out
there and do that if you're doing
whatever if you're playing baseball
basketball soccer football uh being a
doctor or like whatever like if you know
you got your talent if you know you have
put in the work and you know you got
inside of you don't let nobody taking
that away from you so that's kind of
what I that's why I said it and that's
why I keep encouraging people on that
I love hearing that because you really
have to be super strong mentally to hear
all of these things that people are
saying about you soaking it in but
turning it around and knowing who you
are and proving those people wrong did
you always know that all of these things
that you are now have always been inside
of you
now if I say no I will be lying I feel
like I was I have always been working
towards something and I feel like this
y'all this is all part of the hard work
and I feel like we always had a vision
and like thank God and like All His
blessings like we're able to be here
right now and I just grateful for the
people that are around me that they
pushed me to be here and they've lived
in me they were as easy as I was with me
so uh I feel really grateful for that
well I'm very glad that you've had that
mindset because look at all the places
that it has taken you so far and
obviously so much further to go and this
might be a bit of a loaded question but
when you think about your talent what
you have done so far what you will be
able to do how good can you be what's
that ceiling uh I mean I don't know how
good I can be I just feel like I never
really think about that I feel like I
always think of how good can I be today
like how like
how good can I do this at the gym how
good can it is in the cage how good can
I handle myself throughout the day I
feel like that that have helped me to
kind of take out take out a lot of
pressure with like expectations for like
party things I feel like at the end of
the day if you do the right thing right
now it's gonna take care for everything
else and the rest so that's gonna how I
approach it just one day at a time and
just kind of have fun with it and like
enjoy where my feet are at
how good were you today
I was pretty good I was pretty good I
really I really liked it I really liked
it I I feel like we got better today
good what are some markings for you to
know okay today I got better I improved
I put in the work that I needed to do in
this moment how do you know
I just feel like whenever I get really
tired whenever I don't have like
whenever I don't have fuel inside of me
whenever I just feel my body so beat up
that I'm just all sore and like my
body's feeling I feel that's why I know
like okay we're working because if you
go to the gym and like whenever you're
done like you feel good and you can walk
straight and like you can do all that I
feel like I don't think you work the
hardest you got so I feel like whenever
I feel my body just running empty and
like getting so tired or like getting
busy getting nauseous and all those
things I feel that's whenever I hit my
limit and that's whenever I try to keep
pushing me a little bit and like I feel
like that's when I know okay I think we
got better today
good pushing yourself to kind of that
that Breaking Point that's how you know
that you've done everything that you can
in that moment I love that I'm gonna
adopt that okay so we have seen your
Rookie of the Year season
what would an MVP season look like for
you
I mean definitely has to be better
because if you see the guys around the
league the way they play they play an
outstanding ball so I just feel like
this has to be better and I just keep
God I gotta keep pushing myself and that
is no other way around it the way I had
to do MVP season you just got to be
better than everybody else basically at
the same time I like to win I like to
win I feel like I want to win with my
team man
yeah that's what it's all about MVPs are
cool but I feel like winning
I'm more cool because you're doing the
your whole crew basically
yeah and winning is the answer to all
things right
so it means that you know your team
that it should but it also means that
every person is excelling at their role
and when you do that all of those
personal accolades just come along with
that initial teamwork
um so that's it that's an amazing way to
look at it so when I was research
researching for this obviously I was
looking at a lot of different articles I
know that you're only 22 years old but
there are so many
pieces of work about whether or not you
are going to be a Hall of Famer and I'm
like okay he's 22 years old and we are
putting all of this on to him but
obviously you know I think it's great
because people see the Promise and the
talent that you have within yourself but
do you ever feel pressure or do you see
it as opportunity or does it feel like a
high expectation for people to have on
you so young how do you view it I mean I
feel like having how a favorite career
it just like it just means it just means
to me that you did everything right
that you did everything right on and off
the field and to be honest to have
people considering that I could be one
of those people it gets me excited you
know it gets me more motive to keep
working it's like man that's a really
good thought you had on me and like that
if you were thinking that I could do
that maybe I can so like get me more it
gets me motivated to kind of keep on
going and like keep on working hard like
putting the work in just kind of
motivates me more
no I love that as it should So speaking
of you became the fastest rookie in
baseball history to record 25 home runs
and 25 stolen bases what does that say
about your game
uh but I'm a little bit diverse in that
I can do different things maybe on the
field
[Laughter]
I mean no it's it's super impressive and
I just think that it's really great
especially as we talk about growing the
game of baseball and getting you know
the younger generation into it for there
to be such exciting and diverse and
versatile players that really helps in
terms of people tuning in and wanting to
really enjoy the game and you are one of
those people that's going to be the face
of MLB what does that mean to you
I mean
I don't really think about it so much
about being like the facial movie and
all that I feel like I was trying to
enjoy myself and try to like motivate
people motivate kids like achieve what
they want and like become who they want
to become to have people consider me the
face of baseball or something like that
I mean it is pretty cool it's pretty
cool you know but I really got like
think about it so much but if there's
kids are going to be seeing me kids are
going to be getting motivated by it like
seeing me over there I feel like I was
just trying to do the best thing I can
to keep giving a good example if they're
gonna see me out there I feel like they
got to see me doing the right thing all
the time
for sure okay we have to talk about my
favorite thing that is the Home Run
Derby
I love the Home Run Derby okay so we all
saw you compete put on a crazy show I
want to know about the preparation that
goes into competing in that event
because I'm sure it's pretty strenuous
uh
I feel like it was a new event for me
because I feel like I knew I could hear
your home runs but I've never got into a
serious serious home run therapy I have
done it with my friends and all that but
it was not like so serious like that and
I remember whenever I called a guy that
threw me BP his name is framing he was I
gotta take my cousin like he's he's a
man he was just throwing perfect at a
time I remember whenever I call him
um it was well I was in Texas and that
was the first time I actually like
practice for almost every two like with
time and all that
okay I remember it was pretty tiring it
was pretty tiring but after like a few
rounds I kind of got used to it and I
just just getting the Reps on it like
and just do it over and over and over
that's kind of like where the tricks and
I just kind of how consistent can you
really be like getting into your power
so I mean you stuff but it was fun at
the same time so I really really enjoyed
so was competing in it harder or easier
than you thought
I had a lot of fun with it I thought it
was I mean I don't it's not that I felt
like
I just thought I just enjoyed it a lot I
don't think I didn't think it was hard
like I didn't think it was like
something different that I would have
done before it was different stage for
sure but I feel like in my head I was
just I was hitting MVP just trying to
hit home runs like yeah that's kind of
how I view it and like people were there
just to watch me do that so yeah it also
just felt like a moment that so many so
many people were introduced to you in a
really cool way so I'm happy you did it
okay is winning it a goal of yours are
you considering doing it again tell us
are we gonna see you are we gonna see
you in it baby baby
maybe maybe we'll see we'll see okay
okay we'll see but fingers crossed
because I think that we all want to uh
see you do it again
um okay when I talk about the Mariners a
little bit obviously had been in the
playoff drought for 21 years prior to
last season but when did you know that
you could help end that
I feel like
I want to say in the off season of 2021
by 2021 that's whenever When I Was
preparing myself and like kind of
getting ready for a season I feel like I
was feeling that with this worry that
I've been putting on and
I feel like the way that things are
going I feel like I'll I will be able to
like help a team I was definitely
looking for a chance but in my head I
was like okay if I get the chance like
we gotta win we gotta play to win the
ball game I got to give him 100 every
time and we got to go we got to get
there and I just felt like from the time
that I Was preparing myself that's
whenever I had the motivation like I was
just thinking okay like I think I can
help the team win and I will try to do
my best with it but so that was when you
were like we have something here and we
can make it happen oh no and definitely
like out of screen training like it's
been training too whenever all the guys
you see like all the guys and throughout
the year like how everybody was involved
and kind of figure out themselves like
finding their strength and all that it
was it was pretty cool to see like the
whole team like that's a whole the team
evolving like day in day out they just
kind of rely on each other and like
trusting each other more like kind of
knowing that everybody that was there
was committed to win
you're clearly a very positive person
and a very headstrong person what kind
of motivator are you in the clubhouse
I mean I think I'm the type of guy that
I can't tell you something but at the
same time I'm gonna be right there with
you doing the same thing so
I feel like I'm not gonna tell something
to somebody that I'm not going to be
doing or like that I don't have
experience with or because I don't want
to like both people around I feel like
if I tell you something because I care
about you and I want to help you and if
I see something I'm gonna be straight up
and tell you and but yeah that's kind of
the motivator I am man I feel like it's
always it's better to tell somebody the
truth because then it could become too
late for that person to change it and at
the same time we are all teammates and
we all like basically striving for a
goal I want my teammates to be the best
I can be you know and I feel as me
telling the truth and actually like
being there with them like if we gotta
work we work together like things like
that I feel like that's that's the way I
like motivating people just by telling
them the truth and like showing them
like if I tell you hey you got to be at
the gym I'm gonna be at the gym do
something different probably but I'm
gonna build a gym too yeah so in the
baseball world who motivates you
I feel like a lot of guys I feel like my
teammates are opposing players like
pretty much everybody I can find
motivation into like we play a game and
we'll lose a serious I guess any team I
feel like they motivate me to kind of be
better for the next time I see them to
try to beat them and get the best they
get the best out of the series you know
so I feel like everybody everybody guys
on my trial that he plays really good
against us oh fortunately and he's like
that so I feel like all those guys
motivate me everybody pretty much
I love that okay a couple more for you
uh Julio as you know I cover a lot of
the NBA I think that when we first met
we were talking about that some are you
a big NBA fan I do enjoy watching the
NBA who are some of your favorite
players oh definitely guys like LeBron
Kyrie KD
oh so many super Curry
oh so many of them I really enjoy
watching NBA games
Seattle already has such a vibrant
Sports scene but if they brought back
the Seattle SuperSonics
that City would go crazy I mean you
gotta you gotta start the campaign to
bring them back Julio yeah I thought it
would be pretty cool because I feel like
that the sports in the city are just
gone so for sure yeah it's going a lot
so it will be good so if you have the
SuperSonics back over there yeah you
guys have very strong men's sports and
strong women's sports so I I love
visiting Seattle
um I do want to talk about the World
Baseball Classic because there's so much
talent on Dominican Republic's team just
how stacked is that roster
I just got to say we got a pretty good
team you know we got a pretty good team
man I know those guys are going to be
ready to compete
laying for the Dr
it's just different you're playing for
everything you represent like everything
you can possibly represent everything
that may who you are other people back
home everybody that was in the
neighborhood with you like your friend
like friends families people that you
know I feel like you're representing all
of them so I feel that's why it's a
little bit different whenever you're
playing for your country you have
the emotion that you're just wearing
that flag basically on your shoulders
it's a different feeling
I love it I'm excited to watch all of
you um in that classic okay last one for
you for me at least one of the best
parts of watching you play is that it is
so clear that you are having fun out
there what Joy has baseball brought to
your life
uh I feel like a lot of different type
of Joys I feel like
my family is in a better place because
of that I feel like I'm doing what I
basically my dad taught me since I was a
kid like I'm able to just play the game
that I love a game that was introduced
to me when I was a kid and just being
able to do the whole basically my throw
my whole career so I feel like I just
love being able to play the game love
being able to provide for my family my
family basically watching the same kid
just going out there to the field and
just they just they just watch me on the
TV now so I feel like I really I really
enjoy that they get to watch me play my
family back home everybody so
it's definitely I definitely enjoy
what life lessons has baseball taught
you
um
I want to say that doesn't matter it
doesn't matter
if you throw up you're so down you
always got to stay neutral
I feel like that's doesn't matter what
life throws at you as I was talking here
and I feel basically it's really hard
you always gonna be struggling you're
always gonna something bad is happening
so you always got to stay calm you
always gotta be able to analyze and like
think this through properly so you
cannot be feeling so awful feeling so
down whenever you're taking decisions
like that so I feel like that's
something that basically really time
that you kind of be be honest like on
that same wavelength and now it's being
too high or too low and I was going to
enjoy everything and uh just keep moving
forward
I love that never too high never too low
just stay the course well before we
started this interview we asked if Julio
was ready he said he was born ready and
I think he might be right congrats um on
this campaign
so cool I love it and thank you so much
for joining the show it was beautiful to
see you no thank you good to see you too
[Music]